-Hey, Dan, how are you?
-I'm doing relatively well
I suppose.
How are you?
-I'm doing well I suppose, too
We were talking right
before this started,
you and your dad
were on the show
talking about the premiere
which is insane.
-Yeah, and we bookended.
-We totally bookended it.
And I feel like you went
from a show
that was maybe
a little unknown early on,
to a cult hit,
to a show that last year,
people said
had been snubbed in the Emmys.
And, of course, then,
you probably had a,
I don't know,
fear that would happen again
and the opposite happened.
-Well, yeah, I mean, I think -
let's be honest.
We went from -- I mean,
you were doing us a favor
when you had us
on your show six years ago
because nobody
was watching our show.
And then, slowly,
people ended up catching on.
Yeah, I mean, you know,
I think when you are a sho
that is this small and I think
the fact that people are now
watching it doesn't change
the fact that,
you know, our budget
is still the first
15 seconds of "Mrs. Maisel."
-[ Laughs ]
-For us, it's like, you know
I think when you start out
that small,
you will always be that small.
So, you know, to find out abou
all of the lovely
Emmy news this week was trul
a surprise to all of us.
I mean, I had hoped
that maybe my dad
and Catherine
would get recognized,
but certainly not, you know,
what ended up happening.
None of us
could see that coming.
-You also got nominated
for a show.
You got nominated, Annie,
who plays your sister,
she got nominated.
And, you know, 15 is such
a huge, awesome number,
and yet, it is
a virtual ceremony this year
which you would say
is kind of fitting.
-I would say, like,
if I could write
a "Schitt's Creek"
version of our team
and the Emmys co-existing,
it would have to involve
some sort of, you know,
way that we would
never get there.
So the fact that
we have 15 nominations on a year
that none of us
will be able to attend
feels very "Schitt's Creek,"
which is also kind of
such a lovely thing.
And I hope that we'll all --
I don't know really
what's happening,
but we're all up
in Canada right now,
so I'm hoping that
we'll all just like
have a backyard barbecue
at my dad's house
and, you know, have a few beer
and hope for the best.
-I do want to speak to the fact.
This is a Canadian productio
and I imagine that Canada
must be incredibly proud
about the reception
the show received this week.
-I am really proud.
You know, again, it's like we do
this show
up in Canada three months
out of the year
and then I'm up there,
you know, in edit and post
And, you know, to see these --
to see friends of mine
who are,
you know, behind the scene
who have done
such unbelievable work
on the show getting recognized
at the Emmys,
it's, like, the morning
of the announcements,
we were all just calling eac
other in complete disbelief.
It was -- You could not as
for a better end
to such a lovely story
for all of us.
And you know, our entire cas
and crew started with nothin
and now ended up with Emmy -
I mean, it's a storybook ending.
-It is.
You mentioned everybody
is calling.
And I'm sure you are
being inundated
with press calls as well.
Your sister who plays a waitress
on the show,
she busted you on Instagra
for the fact
that you had not
called her back.
-[ Laughs ]
I saw that.
Well, you know, I guess.
Listen, this is very new to me
but, you know,
I didn't know that when
something like this happens,
you have to sort of spend
the morning
talking to different
press outlets.
And literally just as I woul
get on the phone with someone,
I would see my sister FaceTiming
and I'd have to like,
"Decline, decline."
It happened like three times
and then finally,
she just texted me back --
well, she Instagramed, and then,
she texted me back and was like,
"If you don't pick up the phone,
I will disown you."
-[ Laughs ]
-Fortunately, we are doing well.
I called her back.
And, you know,
she was very excited.
-You mentioned
a fairytale ending.
You know, one of those things as
well is that you had to make -
you know, what I'm assumin
is a difficult decision on
when to end the show.
You guys nailed the landing,
but I assume
your very passionate fan bas
was upset
that you were calling it quits
How did you weigh that decisio
and are you happy
with how it ended up?
-We knew at season
four that we had two more left
and, you know,
I'm always a fan of,
like, shows that start
and finish really strong.
I think for me, you know,
I'm so sensitive when I --
I've jumped off of one too man
shows to know what that's like
And I Wanted to --
-You mean as a viewer,
you've jumped off?
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
-So, you know, for us,
I think when we knew
we had a two-season pickup
and five and six
would be the last,
it was a really nice way
of building toward a conclusio
that we had control over.
But at the same time,
I feel like our fans
have become, like, such
a lovely group of people.
They've raised tens of thousands
of dollars for charity.
They're just so supportive
and my big concern was,
when we put that statement
out saying
that this would be
our last season,
i was expecting a kind of
angry response from all of them.
But the fans were so nice.
They were like,
"No, that's too bad,
and we're very upset,
but how are you?"
-[ Laughs ]
-Like, I don't know
what we've done
to deserve
the kindness of these people
-It is officially the most
Canadian show of all time.
Even the fans.
-It is a very Canadian show.
-[ Laughs ]
You actually, you know --
There will be an absence
of a red carpet
as we have established
with the virtual Emmys.
You worked the red carpet
as a correspondent a few times
-Unfortunately.
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah. That seems so stressful
-It takes a very particula
person to not be soul-crushe
by the experience of, like
interviewing on a red carpet
Because let's be honest --
nobody on the carpet
really wants to talk to anybody.
So being the person that's like,
"Well, where did you get
your dress from," is not -
you're inherently not someon
that the person answering
that question wants to talk to
And yeah, I did it
for the MTV Movie Awards.
And it was like two hours of -
you know, red carpet --
you have to prep for --
you have huge binders
of, like, actors
and what they're, you know
what their role
and what they're here for.
And I'm terrible
at memorizing things,
so I really --
for me, it was a disaster.
And the two-hour carpet ende
and I remember kind of
like walking around the corner
completely dazed
and, like, burst into tears.
I was like,
"I can't do this again.
I just don't have it in me."
I am not Ryan Seacrest.
-You --
Obviously, a big week
because of the nominations
You've won a GLAAD Award.
Was it today?
-Yeah.
It is -- You know,
it's situations like these
that almost in the back
of your mind
make you think, like,
what terrible thing
is going to befall me tomorrow
-[ Laughs ]
-It's been a nice week.
-Yeah, it must be as awards go
the GLAAD Award must be
a special one to win.
-Yeah, I mean, you know,
I have long admired
the organization
and got to work with them
on several occasions.
And, you know, I think to be
recognized by that,
by the community
is such a meaningful thing
especially because I think
our show, you know,
the storylines that we explore
in the show
are such a love letter
to the LGBTQ community.
So, to receive this
kind of honor from GLAAD
is just a really --
is a really special thing.
And, you know,
it's been a very nice day.
-Well, it was
an incredible show.
It was such a great show
about family.
It was even cooler that ther
was such a family connection
to it from the outset.
And congratulations
for all of the accolades.
They're really well-deserved
And thanks for being back
on the show, Dan.
-Thank you very much. Thanks for
having me. Good to see ya.